(upbeat music)
- One time I was flirting with this girl
and we were walking,
and I legit crashed into a sign.
Maybe I should give lessons on how to fail
at getting a girl's number.
(upbeat music)
- I'm really bad at flirting.
A guy calls me "Babe,"
and I spend the next two hours
googling what that could mean.
(upbeat music)
- So awkward when people flirt with me.
Boy: "You're pretty."
Me: "Happy birthday to you as well."
(upbeat music)
- I tried to flirt with
this really cute guy
in my checkout lane.
Turns out he's a doctor and he thought
I was suffering from a
form of anxiety attack.
- I told this cute girl I liked her accent
and asked where it was from.
She said it was a speech impediment.
My flirting skills in a nutshell.
(upbeat music)
- Met a really cute girl.
She started to flirt with me
and asked what my name was.
My response?
"I don't know."
(upbeat music)
- I just started flirting with my fiancé.
He got confused and couldn't catch on,
so now I'm just eating Doritos.
At least they understand
what I want in my mouth.
- One time I was flirting
with a guy and he said,
"I'm loving the whole blonde
hair, blue eyes thing."
And I said, "So did Hitler!"
(upbeat music)